JOIN US.
THEY ARE JENNA ELLIS, STEVE
MOORE, MATT GAETZ.
I WANT TO START WITH YOU, PEOPLE
ARE WORRIED, CONFUSED AND THERE
IS A DIE VERY ZENS -- I DIDGENCE
BETWEEN THE FREE WORLD, ALSO TOO
OFTEN UNHELPFUL, OVER
DRAMATIZING.
>> THE THINNEST OF VIN EARS
SEPARATES US FROM CHAOS.
>> NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO WILL BE
DIAGNOSED WITH CORONAVIRUS WILL
EXPLODE, CAUSE CHAOS, WILL CAUSE
PANDEMONIUM.
STEVE: YET EVERY SINGLE PERSON I
SPOKEN TO IN REAL WORLD,
INCLUDING DOCTORS, ACADEMICS AND
BUSINESS PEOPLE, THEY TALK ABOUT
THE MASSIVE OVERREACTION, IT IS
INSANE.
COMMON REFRAIN.
NOW I DON’T AGREE WITH THAT, BUT
I UNDERSTAND WHY YOU MIGHT BE
THINKING THAT.
IT BECAUSE THERE IS SOMETHING
MISSING IN WHAT WE’RE TOLD BY
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS,
THEY HAVE TOLD US MOST PEOPLE
ARE NOT AT SERIOUS RISK FROM
CORONAVIRUS, ANYONE CAN GET IT
AND SPREAD IT SO FAR, ONLY A
SMALL NUMBER END UP SICK ENOUGH
TO BE HOSPITALIZED.
>> FOR THE MOST PART, THE PEOPLE
WHO GET IN TROUBLE AND
TRAGICALLY WOULD DIE FROM THIS
ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE ELDERLY
AND/OR UNDERLYING CONDITIONS.
BECAUSE OF THE DIFFICULTY IN
BREATHING.
STEVE: THEY ARE ALSO SAYING, THE
KIDS DOWN GET SICK FROM IT.
THE QUESTION IS MANY ARE ASKING,
IF KIDS DON’T GET IT MOST PEOPLE
WHO GET IT ARE FINE, WHY ARE WE
CLOSING DOWN AMERICA TO FIGHT
IT?
LET ME TRY TO EXPLAIN.
IT IS THE BEST WAY TO -- HERE IS
WHAT DR. FAUCI SAID THIS WEEK.
>> IT 10 TIMES MORE LETHAL THAN
SEASONAL FLU .
STEVE: OKAY, BUT HOW DOES THAT
SQUARE WITH THE OTHER THINGS
THAT FEDEXES -- MEDICS HAVE TOLD
US.
TED CRUZ SAID THAT CDC TOLD HIM
LAST WEEK, PROMPTING HIS
SELF-Q
REQUEST.
SELF-QUARANTINE Q.
>> WE HAVE BEEN TOLD MANY
INFECTED PEOPLE WILL NOT HAVE
SYMPTOMS AT ALL.
>> MOST PEOPLE MORE THAN 85%
WILL HAVE MILD OR NO SYMPTOMS.
STEVE: IF WE GET EVERY AMERICAN
TESTED, ACCORDING TO THE CDC, WE
WILL NOT KNOW WHO HAS
CORONAVIRUS, AN ACCURATE DEATH
RATE IS UNKNOWABLE.
IT SEEMS THE IMPORTANT POINT IS
THAT THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
AMERICANS WHO MAY NEED HOSPITAL
TREATMENT AT ANY ONE TIME.
IN HOUSE DOCTOR TOLD CONDITION
CONGRESSIONAL STAFFERS HE IS
EXPECTING 70 TO 150 MILLION
PEOPLE IN U.S. TO CONTRACT THE
VIRUS THAT SOUNDS PLUS PLAUSIBLE
THIS IS MORE CONTAGIOUS THAN A
NORMAL FLU, WHICH HAS INFECTED
UP TO 90 MILLION PEOPLE IN
AMERICA IN A BAD YEAR.
WE HAVE 920,000 HOSPITAL BEDS,
MOST ALREADY IN USE.
ONE ESTIMATE BY A INFECTIOUS
DISEASE EXPERT, SAID 4.8 MILLION
PEOPLE.
IF EVEN A FRACTION OF THAT
NUMBER IS CONCENTRATED AT ONE
POINT IN TIME IT WOULD OVERWHELM
OUR HOSPITAL SYSTEM AND YOU END
UP WITH PATIENTS DYING IN
CORRIDORS LIKE THIS IN ITALY.
WE HAVE TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
HOSPITALIZATIONS AT ANY ONE
TIME, SPREAD IT OUT.
THAT IS STATEET REASON FOR
SCHOOL CLOSURES AND THE NBA, AND
ALL THE REST, LARGE GATHERING,
SPREAD THE INFECTIONS, HEALTHY
PEOPLE CAN LEAVE AND INFECTION
SOMEONE WHO REALLY IS AT RISK
WHO MIGHT NEED HOSPITAL
TREATMENT.
THE IDEA BEHIND CLOSING SCHOOLS
IS NOT TO PROTECT THE KIDS WHO
WILL LIKELY BE FINE, BUT TO
PREDICTION THE GRANDPARENTS FROM
THE KIDS, MANY HEAR THIS FROM
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS THEY
ASK, DOES THAT REALLY ADD UP?
YOU TOLD ME MOST PEOPLE WOULD BE
FINE AND KIDS DON’T GET IT, IF
YOU CLOSE SCHOOL, WILL KIDS BE
MORE LIKELY TO COME IN CONTACT
WITH GRANDPARENTS, ESPECIALLY IF
FAMILY CANNOT AFFORD TO ARRANGER
CHILD CARE, I HAVE A PLEA, YOU
WANT AMERICANS TO COOPERATE.
BUT THERE ARE MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS WHO DON’T BUY INTO
WHAT YOU ARE SAYING, AND
REPEATING IT WILL NOT WORK.
YOU NEED TO ANSWER THE BIG
QUESTION THAT MEMBERSHIP
AMERICANS ARE ASKING.
INSTEAD OF CLOSING SCHOOL,
COLLEGES SPORTS AND OTHER LARGE
GATHERING FOR GENERAL
POPULATION, WHY NOT ISOLATE THE
VULNERABLE POPULATION, LIKE
CALIFORNIA JUST ANNOUNCED,
INSTEAD OF TRA DRACONIAN STEPS T
WILL TANK ECONOMY FOR EVERYONE,
WHY NOT FOCUS ON THOSE MOST AT
RISK?
I AM SURE THERE A GOOD ANSWER TO
THAT QUESTION.
WE HAVE NOT HEARD IT YET.
FROM DR. FAUCI OR ANY OF THEM,
UNTIL WE DO, YOU WILL HAVE
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS NOT
TRUSTING WHAT THE OFFICIALS SAY.
THAT IS LAST THING WE NEED AT A
TIME OF NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
STILL.
IN WORDS OF A BRITISH GOVERNMENT
OFFICIAL, I USED TO WORK WITH,
WE ARE WHERE WE ARE.
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD UNDERSTAND
THE NEW REALITY AND NEW
POLITICAL REALRY REALITY, BALANC
TIPPED.
FROM THE PERCEPTION THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP MISHANDLED THE
CRISIS.
THE ANTITRUMP CULT WILL SAY HE
HAS WHATEVER HE HAS DONE.
>> HORRIBLE PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS.
>> PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES
DOES NOT CARE ABOUT US.
HE DOES NOT CARE ABOUT US, HE
DOES NOT CARE ABOUT THE PUBLIC.
>> YOU LOOK AT HIS STATEMENTS,
ALMOST AS IF DONALD TRUMP IS
WORKING TO TANK THE STOCK
MARKET.
>> EVERYONE IN AMERICA KNOWS
THAT PRESIDENT LIES, BUT HE LIES
ABOUT THINGS THAT MATTER AND
DON’T MATTER, BUT NOW WE HAVE A
CRISIS.
THEY KNOW HE IS LYING.
>> THEY ARE THE ONES LYING, THE
PRESIDENT DID ACT, BOLDLY,
RESTRICTING TRAVEL FROM CHINA,
EPICENTER OF IT, THEN EUROPE,
THE NEW EPICENTER.
HELPING NURSING HOMES, SIGNING
8.3 BILLION AID PACKAGE, WORKING
WITH INSURANCE COMPANIES TO
COVER TESTING COSTS AND
PROVIDING AID TO SMALL
BUSINESSES, AND EMERGENCY
DECLARATION, THAT WILL UNLOCK
MORE FUNDING AND UNLEASH THE
HELP SYSTEM AND NATIONAL MERGE
SERVICES.
-- EMERGENCY SERVICES, WE’LL
HAVE MORE ON THE ECONOMIC IMPACT
LATER.
BUT EVEN GAVIN NEWSOM, PRAISE
THE PRESIDENT’S ACTION.
>> I HAD A PRIVATE CONVERSATION
WITH HIM AROUND 4:30 WEST COAST
TIME, HE SAID EVERYTHING THAT I
COULD HAVE HOPED FOR, WE HAD A
VERY LONG COB VERY CONVERSATION,
EVERYTHING SINGLE THING HE SAID,
THEY FOLLOWED THROUGH ON.
STEVE: THE QUESTION IS WHAT TO
DO NEXT?
I HAVE TWO BIG RECOMMENDATION,
FIRST MEDICAL CAPACITY, IF THERE
IS CHAOS IN THE HOSPITAL,
PRESIDENT TRUMP CAN SAY GOOD-BYE
TO A SECOND TERM, WORLD WILL BE
WATCHING.
DON’T LET AMERICA’S HOSPITALS
BECOME THE EQUIVALENT OF
CALIFORNIA’S HOMELESS CRISE, SET
A TARGET HALF A MILLION EXTRA
HOSPITAL BEDS, GET THEM IN
HOTELS, GET FEMA IN GET MILITARY
IN, START BUILDING NOW, BUILD
HOSPITALS AND CLINICS, TRUMP IS
A BUILDER.
GET THE PROTECTIVE GEAR, AND
RESPIRATORS AND ICUS, GET AHEAD.
DR. FAUCI SAID WE HAVE 12700
VENTILATORS IN STOCK PILE BUT WE
MAY NEED HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS.
WE’RE NOT READY.
IF WE WERE.
GET THE PRIVATE SECTOR IN
GENIUSES IN SILICON VALLEY TO
STOP WORKING ON TRAVEL TO MARS
AND GET THEM TO FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO PROVIDES RESPIRATORY CARRY.
INSPIRE THEM.
SECOND, REPATRIOT AMERICAN
MANUFACTURING, MEDICAL
MANUFACTURING STARTING NOW, OUR
DEPEND ON CHINA IS A NATIONAL
SECURITY RISK, I’VE BEEN SAYING
IT DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN SAYING
IT FOR DECADE, PRESIDENT IS
WORKING -- AN EXECUTIVE ORDER ON
THIS, THAT IS GREAT NEWS, IT
SHOULD INCLUDE A FORMAL POLICY.
OF INDUSTRIAL REPATRIATION, A
LIST OF PRODUCTION THAT MUST BE
LOCATED IN AMERICA, INCLUDING
ESSENTIAL PHARMACEUTICAL AND A
DECOUPLING FROM CHINA, WE CAN
TRADE WITH THEM, SURE, BUT WE
CANNOT BE DEPEND EN ANT ON THEM
ANYTHING.
>> IF YOU WANT TO SELL IT IN
AMERICA YOU HAVE TO MAKE IT IN
AMERICA.
THAT SIMPLE.
ONE MORE THOUGHT.
I FELT PROUD FRIDAY WATCHING THE
ROSE GARDEN PRESS CONFERENCE,
AND LUCKY TO BE HERE, LOOK HOW
THIS COUNTRY IS RESPONDING,
PRIVATE SECTOR, STATE, LOCAL
GOVERNMENT, INDIVIDUALS, THIS IS
AMERICA.
STANDING UP TO THIS NEW UNSEEN
ENEMY AND A AMERICAN BOMB BOTTOM
GRASSROOTS WAY.
THIS NOT THE HOME OF PUNEY
VASELATION, THIS IS THE LAND OF
THE FREE AND THE HOME OF THE
BRAVE, THAT IS WHY WE WILL BEAT